il est d'imposer son régime de sanctions
au niveau international il y rend en
grave difficulté au plan économique et
social pour la chine c'est une très
belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences
les iraniens avaient ils un autre choix
face aux pressions américaines en tous
genres par notre incapacité à répondre à
ces attentes légitimes
nous les avons nous pas pousser dans les
bras d'un partenaire qui va en profiter
pour faire de l'iran sa tête de pont au
moyen orient
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes aéro pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions sans trop savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien on a trente
sept cantons à un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine à bellecin fabrique une petite
fièvre couvre quelque chose la planète l
année là aujourd'hui chacun a ses
activités impact la nature impacte notre
les questions environnementales
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique jean
jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal quittant
comprenant le réel
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite fait les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 5 octobre 2020
de nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
deux semaines avec la fermeture des bars
colloque de sport piscine ou bien encore
les universités contrainte de limiter
leur capacité d'accueil à paris et la
proche banlieue sont passés en état d'
alerte maximale depuis hier soir à les
restaurants en revanche peuvent rester
ouverts dans la capitale avec un
protocole sanitaire renforcée ceux de la
région de marseille sont rouverts elle
la cité phocéenne va d'ailleurs se doter
de son propre conseil scientifique pour
évaluer la situation sanitaire dans le
territoire disputé du haut karabagh les
troupes séparatistes se retire je cite
de certains secteurs du front à des fins
tactiques indiqué la présidence de cette
république autoproclamée
engagé dans un conflit armé avec
l'azerbaïdjan
voilà neuf jours maintenant que
s'affrontent les forces séparatistes
arménienne et l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
l'otan appelle la turquie a usé de son
influence pour calmer les tensions
[Musique]
outre atlantique la décision sera connue
dans les prochaines heures celle de la
sortie ou non de l'hôpital de donald
trump
depuis l'annoncé la semaine dernière de
la contamination coville 19 du locataire
de la maison blanche elle les messages
contradictoires ont semé le trouble sur
son état de santé dans son entourage sa
porte parole est également testée
positive
et on débute avec l'actualité du jour en
france dominée par les nouvelles mesures
de restriction pour paris et sa petite
couronne on le rappelle placées en zones
d'alert maximale les annonces ont été
faites à midi au cours d'une conférence
de presse
un autre reporter bassin chebbi l'a
suivi face à la recrudescence de cas de
contamination coronavirus le
gouvernement a décidé de mettre en place
des nouvelles mesures des mesures qui
seront applicables pour paris et la
petite couronne à partir de demain et ce
pour 15 jours jusqu'au 19 octobre ces
nouvelles mesures sont applicables
notamment pour les bars qui seront
fermés à partir de demain les
restaurants eux pourront être ouverts
rester ouverts ils fonctionneront
normalement mais devront appliquer un
protocole sanitaire assez strictes les
salles de sport elle reste fermée
les soirées étudiantes et les fêtes type
mariage sont strictement interdits pour
les 15 premiers pros prochain jeu au
pardon tout ce qui est foires
expositions salons congrès également
interdit les 15 prochains jours
concernant ces informations donc le
gouvernement a décidé d'appliquer ces
restrictions et interdire tout
rassemblement de plus de 1000 personnes
et tout rassemblement de plus de 10
personnes sur les places publiques les
théâtres musées eux resteront ouverts
ainsi que les marchés et l'ensemble des
transports en commun de la région ile de
france la mairie de paris a annoncé que
ces mesures seront accompagnés par le
gouvernement la mairie ainsi que par les
forces de police je vous propose
d'écouter la maire de paris anne hidalgo
nous avons tous conscience que nous
entrons dans une phase nouvelle parce
que évidemment ce virus est là
durablement percute nos vies et que nous
devons et c'est le sens de cette réunion
est de cette conférence commune
travailler tous ensemble d'abord pour
protéger et ça nous devons le faire
ensemble avec des mesures qui bien sûr
pour un certain nombre sont des mesures
sanitaires sont la base de ces mesures
elles ont été exprimées
par la rs il ya des mesures de police de
police administrative pour permettre
cette protection
et puis il ya aussi des mesures
d'accompagnement social que la ville
évidemment dans sa double qualité de
ville et de département a d'ores et déjà
engagé d'ailleurs depuis la phase de
confinement des mesures pour faire face
à cette recrudescence de coronavirus je
vous rappelle que le taux d'incidence
est de 260 pour 100000 habitants dans la
région ile de france avec un taux
d'occupation des lits en réanimation de
36% le gouvernement souhaite ralentir sa
propagation du coronavirus à paris et
dans sa région et un site bien sûr le
télétravail un maximum en attendant que
la situation s'améliore dans la région
et à marseille la lutte contre le coc
u19 prend une nouvelle tournure la
deuxième adjointe de la ville et samia
ghali a rappelé aujourd'hui sa volonté
de créer un conseil scientifique et
l'idée a été adopté lors du conseil
municipal ce lundi
plus d'explications avec cyrielle
benavides bullion la cité phocéenne en
quête d'indépendance du moins
d'indépendance sanitaires pour cela la
deuxième adjointe à la mairie
samia ghali après initiative inédite
je pense qu'il est important de créer un
conseil scientifique de la ville de
marseille avec les collectivités la
préfecture li a chu l'ap-hm
l'hôpital privé les marins-pompiers voir
la cci l'éducation nationale tous ces
organismes qui sont au contact de la
situation sanitaire au quotidien il faut
permettre à la mère de marseille d'avoir
des discussions sur le co vide et
d'autres questions et faire en sorte que
des personnalités marseillaise puisse
discuter et faire des propositions
plutôt que de laisser faire l'état la
proposition de l'ancienne sénatrice qui
avaient émergé à la fin du mois d'avril
a été validé par le conseil municipal ce
lundi marseille va se doter de son
propre conseil scientifique mais c'est
madame la maire justement michel rubio
la médecin de profession
qui devrait le président et quant au
professeur didier rahout il pourrait lui
aussi en être membres selon samia ghali
si peu de détails sur cette nouvelle
instance ont pour l'instant été dévoilé
le message lui semble clair les élus
marseillais ne souhaite plus dépendre de
certains scientifiques parisien un avis
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
je rappelle qu'il existe déjà à
l'échelle nationale comme à l'échelle
locale 10 instances compétentes en
matière sanitaire dans cette crise
chacune de ces structures à une
expertise propre et un rôle à jouer
venir y ajouter un machin purement
marseillais ne peut qu'ajouter de la
confusion et de la cacophonie un
désordre déjà inquiétant une annonce qui
intervient au moment où les restaurants
de la métropole
aix marseille peuvent enfin rouvrir
après une semaine de fermeture imposée
par le gouvernement alors que la
capitale placée en zone d' alerte
maximale depuis lundi matin n'a pour le
moment subi aucune fermeture de ses
restaurants dans les zones d'alerté
maximale c'est donc parti pour quinze
jours avec des mesures afin de tenter de
freiner le regain de l'épidémie pour les
entreprises la ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes rappelle la nécessité
de privilégier plus que jamais le
télétravail et pour revenir sur ces
annonces et ses conséquences place à
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fabrice di vizio avocat bonsoir à vos
côtés olivier maire et au patron du
meeting un bar restaurant dans le 19e
arrondissement de la capitale bonsoir
nous a rejoint également alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir alors à distance
entre les tables carnet de contacts gels
hydro alcooliques sur toutes les tables
désormais un nouveau protocole sanitaire
est donc mise en place dans les
restaurants
olivier marais d'eau quel est votre
sentiment est ce que vous êtes
finalement soulagé de ne pas fermer ce
soir ou alors inquiets face à de
nouvelles mesures contraignantes
un avis très partagés partagé parce
qu'encore une fois on est prévenus au
dernier moment
alors à l'heure actuelle on n'a pas
encore le texte officiel 1 sur ce qu'on
doit appliquer exactement heureusement
les syndicats etc
quand même fait leur boulot et nous ont
donné les grandes lignes
aujourd'hui c'est une profession qui a
encore stigmatisé
on sait par les cafés bars des restos a
alors que les cafés bars et la vie d'un
quartier
aujourd'hui ils doivent fermer c'est pas
uniquement de la vente d'alcool un bar
uniquement qui a des tables aujourd'hui
on va parler comprends pas pourquoi il
peut pas accès à accepter des clients
les installer les faire un service à 6
comme dans un resto attrait pour les
mesures qui nous sont propres
on a la chance aujourd'hui de pouvoir
ouvrir et quand je dis la chance il va
falloir faire les calculs on avait
jusqu'à maintenant le temps qu'ils
étaient pour nous les terrasses ce que
j'appelle les terrasses hidalgo les
extensions terrasse qu'on nous avait
comme vous avez donnée qui nous
permettait d'avoir une activité
cohérente
aujourd'hui les gens vont se mettre à
l'intérieur de nos de nos affaires et on
a une obligation de rentabilité qui est
clair et avec toutes les restrictions
qui sont mises aujourd'hui va falloir
faire le calcul
est ce que c'est encore rentable
d'ouvrir ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux
fermer en attendant que ça passe et m où
tout le monde au chômage partiel
et pour nous les patrons faire le dos
rond parce que les indemnités sont
inexistantes
on va le savoir très rapidement en tout
cas à propos de ces nouvelles
restrictions concernant les bars et les
restaurants regardez ce que disait hier
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin bien sûr que c'est difficile
nous sommes les français nous aimons
boire manger vivre sourire nous
embrasser mais nous le faisons
évidemment parce que la population aussi
le souhaite alors alexis poulard au fond
le gouvernement répond à l'attenté des
français comme vient de comme
l'expliquent gérald darmanin
non absolument pas le gouvernement dans
cette affaire depuis le début gère la
pénurie en mars il gère la pénurie de
masques alors les masques ne sont pas
nécessaires et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
confirme en général aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il gère la pénurie de lits
la pénurie de formation de soignants à
la réanimation
donc on fait semblant on va re confiné
d'une certaine façon on force les
restaurateurs à fermer ou bien mettre
des mesures coercitives avec
l'interdiction de la vente d'alcool à
partir de 22h les bars qui ferment tout
cela n'a aucun sens parce que
aujourd'hui nous l'apprenons en région
parisienne et à paris
203 des clusters qui sont sortis sur les
203 cluster 40% c'est à l'école et à
l'université et la hume seule mesure sur
l'université c'est le présentiel différé
sur l'école
rien du tout ce gouvernement dans cette
crise sanitaire n'a jamais rien fait
pour prévoir pour planifier pendant
l'été on a vu et emmanuel macron sur un
jet ski on a vu jean michel blanquer air
à la plage il ya eu des conseils de
défense bien entendu mais tout a été
fait comme si la rentrée allait se
passer sans encombre comment ils ont pu
penser ça une seule seconde le
déconfinement qui a été gérée au cabinet
américain bain and company la filiale
française est un fiasco total géré par
un monsieur qui s'appelle jean castex ce
qui se trouve être notre premier
ministre
ça devrait nous poser des problèmes
comment ces gens qui ont si mal organisé
le déconfinement peuvent-ils aujourd'hui
gérer la vie avec le virus avec
uniquement des mesures coercitives qui
ne sont pas du tout ce que demandent les
français contrairement à ce que dit
sudermann les français ils demandent
simplement à ce que les gouvernants
gouvernent c'est à dire qu'il défende
les intérêts nationaux qu'ils défendent
les populations face à une crise
sanitaire qui les dépasse aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'ils sont dépassés
la preuve en est faire référence
demander de l'aide au secteur privé avec
le cabinet bnn compagnie la même chose
pour l'usiné bridgestone ont fait appel
au privé pour dire comment sauver les
emplois
non ces gens là sont élus ils sont là
pour gouverner aujourd'hui ils subissent
cette crise et nous font subir leur
incurie je crois que on a été
suffisamment patient à marseille je
comprends le choix de madame ruby rola
de faire un conseil sanitaire à
l'échelle d'une ville parce que ce qui
se passe à l'échelle d'un pays
aujourd'hui c'est les shadoks alors
effectivement à marseille samia ghali a
défendu la création d'un conseil
scientifique
fabrice di vizio on vous voyait dire non
ce n'est pas une bonne idée pourquoi
n'importe quoi enfin excusez moi mais ne
trouve pas que c'est suffisamment le
bordel comme ça ja pardon pardon d'être
franc mais ne trouvez pas que c'est
suffisamment le bordel comme ça vous
avez un nombre incalculable j'ai dû tout
à l'heure il disait renaud muselier 10
instance et 10 instance on en rajoute
une ancienne et leur tient on a qu'a
effectivement moi j'habite à rambouillet
bah je voudrais bien aussi mon conseil
scientifique à rambouillet j'ai un
hôpital et puis pas loin j'ai une
clinique aussi à trappes
je voudrais bien conseil scientifique à
trappes il m'avait semblé comprendre que
l'état était unitaire dans ce pays que
nous n'étions pas dans des lander ou
dans des états fédérés américains et que
effectivement le centralisme n'était pas
forcément un inconvénient quand il est
des bienfaits de répondre à la réalité
des territoires selon vous c'est pas
réalité il n'ya pas de réalité des
territoires
il ya une réalité que deux réalités
nationales on a un virus qui circule sur
le territoire national alors avec plus
ou moins d'incidence et dans les régions
mais je veux dire alors demain matin
est-ce qu'il faut que marseille se dote
de son propre conseil de défense et son
papa conseil de sécurité à quand une
police municipale armée est
effectivement un tribunal et une loi
marseillais
vous voulez quoi rétablir les coutumes
le coutumier du mauvais this tenir parce
qu'on en est là à un moment donné c'est
à dire qu'effectivement concrètement il
m'avait semblé que l'état unitaire et
que l'unité de l'état est un progrès
dans l'histoire du droit là tout à coup
on est en train d effectivement rester
veut restaurer des espèces de coutume
locale avec des conseils locaux
mais tout ça va engendrer une confusion
supplémentaire la vérité pardonnez-moi
mais relativement simple et je partage
au combien david alexis poulain sur ce
point c'est que nous avons un
gouvernement qui ne gouverne pas alors
est ce que parce qu'il gouverne pas il
faut que d'autres le fassent à sa place
ben le problème c'est qu'on afin de
faire un coup d'état là peu ou prou il
est là le problème de fond est par
ailleurs jamais vertu a répété depuis le
premier jour dans cette crise que ce
pays n'est pas gouverné le gall ministre
est mal
au demeurant nous n'avons pas de
gouvernement premiers éléments moi je
vis en temps partiel en italie et j'ai
un cabinet à rome regardez l'italie
l'italie à gérer le problème des le
déconfinement elle a masqué les gens il
ya un protocole universitaire qu'il ya
un protocole social en france on a dit
en juin partez en vacances et en
septembre
mais enfin mais kate vous allez faire en
vacances tout ça c'est de votre faute
et enfin dernier pour sauver du
réanimation pardonnez-moi vient on à 30
% des lits de réanimation mais dieu soit
loué on pourrait en avoir 60
si le virus était arrivé dans deux ans
on aurait eu 60 % des lits de
réanimation qui aurait été occupée
puisque toute façon on les ferme et lits
de réanimation donc venir dire il ya 30
% des lits de réanimation qui sont
occupés tout en fermant délit c'est
forcément biaisé un moment donné les
statistiques
olivier mr et oh vous avez le sentiment
ce soir finalement de payer pour un
certain amateurisme du gouvernement
amateurisme pour reprendre les mots de
bernard martin c'est le président de
l'union des métiers de l'industrie de
l'hôtellerie en paca qui disait ne pas
voir bien clair dans ces nouvelles
mesures
depuis le 14
mars on a réellement l'impression d'être
le marqueur de l'action politique du
gouvernement
d'équidés qu'on doit marquer une action
on agit sur nous ce que disait votre
éditorialistes tout à l'heure 40% des
clusters dans les universités 26 % dans
les entreprises 10% dans le cercle
familial
là les chr n'apparaissent nulle part et
pourtant et pourtant les principales
mesures qui sont prises sont contre nous
et sans nous donner de visibilité il ya
dix jours on nous allons nous as très
lié à servir uniquement après 22h des
gens qu'ils dînaient etc etc
avec toutes les dérives que ça comporte
je vous donne un exemple très rapidement
jeudi soir un les amis qui a une
brasserie de fait tout le protocole tel
qui doit être et 12 policiers qui
débarquent tous policiers c'est pas deux
policiers qui font du zen
ça veut dire qu on a des directives et
qui les indigne pourquoi parce que les
gens qui sont à table et qui ont dîné
l'état brut et des services en train de
finir leurs bouteilles
eh bien non l'alcool ne doit accompagner
que les plats sains et donc fallait
laisser les assiettes sur les tables ce
qui fait que moi j'étais pas là ce
week-end j'ai donné comme directive ce
qui est ce qui est hallucinant on veut
qu en tant que chef d'entreprise d'un
billet de dans la restauration
j'ai donné les directives à mes employés
de ne pas desservir les tables ce qui
fait que tous les gens ont terminé leur
repas devant des assiettes sales
découvert salle 1
pourquoi parce qu'on avait la peur de se
prendre un avertissement il faut savoir
qu'un avertissement c'est pas un
avertissement de la fonction publique
qui après cinq avertissements donne un
blâme et 5 grammes
une promotion et une mutation à un
avertissement chez nous 1 le deuxième
celle une fermeture administrative
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce
de je sais pas si c'est de l'amateurisme
en tout cas on est dans dans pour nous
dans une vision de l'avenir
et là on nous a donné des directives
pour 15 jours en nous disant que dans
quinze jours on fait un nouveau point
donc là il va falloir que je rajoute du
jld à l'aise sur toutes les tables enfin
bon il ya plein de petites mesures des
petites mesurettes qui change
strictement rien en fait au
fonctionnement du bistrot sinon nous
apporter les nouvelles contraintes et de
nouveau moyen de nous sanctionner à et
donc un jour peut-être qu'on va fermer
peut-être que il se passera à autre
chose peut-être qu'il faudra qu'on
réduise encore
de 30% les les tables et c est donc pour
nous c'est on a vraiment l'impression
d'être stigmatisés et d'être encore une
fois j'aurais utilise l'expression parce
que parce que elle est vraie le marqueur
de l'action politique
alors on veut dire qu'on fait quelque
chose on nous tape dessus fabrice di
vizio donc les cafés les restaurants
marqueur de cette action politique en
attendant on en parlait les écoles et
les universités
bon elles sont aussi concernés par ces
nouvelles mesures on le rappelle elle
représente 75% des clusters les
nouvelles mesures selon vous est-ce
qu'elles sont suffisantes elle ce
qu'elles sont efficaces ou alors il
aurait fallu peut-être prendre davantage
en compte le problème des clusters dans
les écoles et les universités au fabrice
division est ce que vous savez que le
protocole sanitaire sur le lieu de
travail donc relatif au lieu de travail
a été allégé est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que aujourd'hui les open space
qui jusqu'ici le masque était
obligatoire en toutes circonstances et
bien ne l'est plus puisqu'on a accordé
des dérogations premiers éléments
deuxième élément sur les universités
vous avez entendu les ministres vous
dire que en fait les universités
n'étaient pas des clusters et entendu
les dire c'est pas des clusters vous
avez entendu le ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur à avoir
l'outrecuidance de dire que dans un bar
on a un virus qui circulent mais dans un
amphi où il ya deux mille personnes qui
sont côte à côte sur à l'amphi de 1200
places et bassa le virus ne circule pas
si vous voulez qu'avec ça on est encore
confiance au gouvernement il faut
sérieusement s'accrocher quand même non
c'est pas des amateurs
je répète depuis le premier jour
pardonnez-moi de réutiliser cette
expression c'est pas des masses amateurs
c'est des branquignols nous avons
affaire à des branquignols c'est tout à
des gens qui n'ont absolument rien
compris qu'ils ne savent rien il a mr
emmanuel macron avait dit soyez des
amateurs il a raison il que l'on a pris
au mot nous n'avons pas de gouvernement
dans ce pays nous sommes le pillon
probablement le
here dieu soit loué nous ne sommes pas
face à ebola c'est tout ce qui nous
console alors ce que sinon on serait
tous morts
alors en attendant ses métros bondés
beaucoup le souligne sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est le cas du député la france
insoumise sébastien lâché au regard des
l'allemand ferme les bars les salles
interdit les rassemblements et les
événements mais les travailleurs
s'entassent dans des transports bondé et
dysfonctionnelle l' alerte maximale
summum de la politique incohérente de
macron face au co vite 10,9 alors alexis
poulain la mise du travail elisabeth
bornes
elle appelle les employeurs et salariés
à s'organiser pour recourir au
télétravail autant que possible dans les
zones d' alerte renforcée et maximale
est ce que c'est une bonne réponse pour
éviter de voir les photos qu'on a vu et
qui circule sur les réseaux sociaux avec
des rames de métros bondés mais c'est
une piètre réponse qu'on parle
d'amateurs fier de branquignols ou de
shadocks on voit bien que cette gestion
de crise n'a aucun sens et qu'elle est
incompréhensible pour le commun des
mortels marlène schiappa était très fier
ce matin d'annoncer que le plan le
nouveau protocole sanitaire des bars
avaient été écrits dans la nuit mais
enfin comment on peut être fier
d'annoncer une chose pareille ça veut
dire que dans la nuit sur un coin de
table on a dit qu'il allait falloir
mettre du gel hydroalcoolique sur les
tables et faire empêcher finalement les
restaurateurs de travail et les métros
ce matin évidemment que dans les métros
le virus n'existe pas mais d'où ça sort
comment on peut dire des inepties
pareilles des mensonges pareil sur les
biens sur les amphithéâtres bondés dans
le dans les facultés
la rentrée n'a pas été préparé la
rentrée des entreprises n'a pas été
préparé non plus et voilà où nous en
sommes et plutôt que d'inciter au
télétravail ça va bien dans certains
secteurs on peut le faire mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut à la fois que le
management soit responsable que les gens
soient formés au télétravail qui faisait
les outils pour le faire aujourd'hui
tout ça marche dans certains secteurs et
encore et que faites vous de tous les
secteurs où le télétravail est
impossible il faut bien se rendent au
travail et donc dans des métros bondés
c'est un vrai problème est là aucune
mesure du goût
ornements ni sur les métros ni sur la
façon de gérer les afflux de population
à un client dans les centres commerciaux
sur 5 ou 4 4 ou 5 mètres carrés bon très
bien alors là comment on va calculer je
ne sais pas mais encore une mesure
fantastique a annoncé par le préfet là
aussi formidables ces mesures de
coercition sont annoncés par un préfet
on n'a même plus besoin maintenant d'un
premier ministre d'un responsable
sanitaire
ce sont les préfets qui choisit par
emmanuel macron qui décide comment le
territoire est éclatée alors oui ça ne
gouverne plus sage erp une crise sans la
gérer parce que finalement on a affaire
à un gouvernement qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts qui n'est pas fait pour ça faire
des fusions acquisitions ça marche
travaillé avec des cabinets privés de
conseil comme bnm compagnie ça marche
mais quand une crise sanitaire majeure
arrive il n'y a plus personne
et aujourd'hui je suis désolé c'est les
français qui font ce qu'ils peuvent pour
continuer bien d'aller travailler
protéger leurs enfants quand vous avez
des parents qui mettent leurs enfants
dans des nids à qu'ovide que sont les
écoles ou les facs
mais qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'ils
pensent les gens que c'est normal que
derrière on va faire confiance à ce
gouvernement qui continue de mentir qui
continuent de mettre des mesures
ridicules sur des bars des restaurants
qui ne sont pas responsables de la
contamination
donc je crois qu'à un moment c'est
normal qu'on n'est plus confiance c'est
normal que les régions les villes chacun
essaye de faire ce qu'il peut pour dire
moi je vais prendre en charge finalement
là où le gouvernement s'arrête parce que
aujourd'hui mais on voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas de stratégie
il n'y a pas de planification et que ce
virus si on va vivre longtemps avec eh
bien on va vivre longtemps avec des
mesures idiote comme celle qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment fabrice di
vizio parmi les travailleurs qui
prennent le métro les soignants qui sont
en première ligne
le directeur général de l'ap-hp martin
hirsch a dit souhaiter aujourd'hui que
les soignants renoncent à leurs vacances
de la toussaint qu'ils seront indemnisés
fabrice division vous qui défendez à des
professionnels de santé
comment cette annonce peut-elle être
perçue est reçu comme une provocation
c'est une provocation c'est la marque de
l'humiliation dire que nous avons à
faire un directeur général de l'ap-hp
nous avons affaire à un ministre de la
santé médecin un directeur général de la
santé qui a disparu d'ailleurs qui
effectivement sont capables du
il y ait des gens qui sont à bout de
forces moi je les vois tous les jours
les soignants dans mon cabinet ils sont
à bout de nerfs
à bout de forces ça va mal finir cette
histoire ne peut que mal finir
on ne peut pas faire travailler des gens
sentent heures par semaine on peut pas
faire travailler les gens douze mois sur
douze en réanimation en soins intensifs
au bloc chirurgical et le tout tenez
vous bien sans protection le taux tenez
vous bien
aujourd'hui les nouvelles directives
c'est quand vous êtes testé positif si
vous n'êtes pas symptomatique venez
travailler
si vous n'êtes qu'à contacter et vous
n'êtes pas symptomatique
venez travailler ça va mal finir et le
jour où ça finira mal
il se trouvera toujours un juge à
distance de l'épidémie pour dire que
c'est pas de la faute du gouvernement
est de la faute du médecin parce que
c'est lui qui sera en première ligne et
que concrètement c'est ça que je vis
tous les jours un système judiciaire
c'est que les médecins paye devant la
justice l'incurie de l'état et la
capacité des pouvoirs publics à les
protéger
et ça va je le répète marc donnez moi
une dernière fois mal finir
ça ne peut que mal finir olive va finir
par des suicides
ça va finir par des burn out ça va finir
par des fautes médicales
mais ça va mal finir olivier mr et oh le
mot de la fin alors les manifestations
restent autorisés à 1 malgré l' alerte
maximale est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
une mobilisation des patrons de bars des
restaurants dans les prochains jours je
l'espère je l'espère vraiment parce
qu'on ne peut pas regarder se contenter
de regarder nous à faire mourir parce
que c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui on essaie de sauver les
meubles mais on les regarde mourir et il
y en a beaucoup qui sont à bout au bout
il ya des drames qui vont ceux qui vont
se trouver dans cette profession et
c'est ce qui est terrible voilà donc
j'espère oui qui aura une forte
mobilisation
j'espère aussi que que les clients vont
pas céder à cette espèce d'eau message
de la peur qui est transporté qui
stigmatisent cette profession en dix ans
on a l'impression alors qu'on est d'en
haut
aucun cluster à cons alors qu'on a
l'impression que tout passe par chez
nous a donc je dis à nos clients
continuent à vivre continuer à respirer
et une et le faire chez nous et puis
puis à tous les gens de la profession
faut rester unis
en séparant les bars et les restos on
crée un clivage qui n'a pas lieu d'être
aujourd'hui resto unis et groupés et
battons-nous pour nos droits et pour
faire jaillir nos entreprises merci
olivier mr et oh je rappelle que vous
êtes patron du meeting bar restaurant
dans le 19e arrondissement de paris
merci avoue fabrice di vizio
elle rappelle que vous êtes avocat un
merci à vous également alexis poulain
éditorialistes et dans quelques instants
nous prendront la direction du haut
karabagh l'otan appelle la turquie a usé
de son influence pour calmer les
tensions entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
et puis direction les états unis la
communication autour de l'état de santé
de donald trump testés positifs au co
lead alimente toutes les spéculations
à moins d'un mois de la présidentielle a
tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
oui
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' valable moi c'est fini pour
moi est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la
radicalisation mais c'est la
radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative en sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui j'ai amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que le président ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face ont pu fiction posent à
nous tant au niveau interne au ft un
climat particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire était violence sous prétexte
dont une manifestation et d'expression
de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
et
[Musique]
des monnaies
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20h30
heure française
azerbaïdjan arménie les deux parties
semblent s'enliser dans le conflit un
bilan partiel fait état de 219 soldats
et 63 civils tués mais chaque camp
indique avoir infligé plusieurs milliers
de pertes humaines à l'adversaire elles
les forces arméniennes ont indiqué
s'être retiré de certains secteurs du
front une manoeuvre tactique selon les
autorités du haut karabagh face à ce
conflit
les diplomaties s'organise guilmard aux
[Applaudissements]
témoins de la guerre au haut karabagh la
communauté internationale s'organise
lentement après plus d'une semaine de
combats meurtriers et toujours aucune
issue au conflit
l'heure est à la coordination des forces
diplomatiques avec pour fer de lance la
coprésidence du groupe de minsk
créée il ya près de trente ans lors de
la première crise du haut karabagh un
groupe conduit notamment par la russie
arbitre privilégie dans ce conflit et
qui ce lundi a fait part de l'avancée
des discussions quant au haut karabagh
nous restons en contact avec des partie
arménienne et azéri ainsi qu'avec les
pays voisins la turquie l'iran
aujourd'hui nous avons discuté entre
autres de la situation au karabagh avec
jean yves le drian
les trois co présidents les présidents
russes français et américains ont fait
une forte déclaration nous préparons
actuellement une déclaration des
ministres des affaires étrangères des
trois pays
et bien sûr il faut penser non seulement
aux déclarations mais aussi aux mesures
concrètes qui peuvent être prises pour
mettre fin à l'effusion de sang et
reprendre la voie des négociations au
soir or ce moteur des préparatifs à de
futures négociations confirmée par le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères la france est mobilisée pour
un cessez le feu au karabagh et pour la
reprise des négociations
nous sommes convenus de l'urgence avec
mon collègue russe dans le cadre de nos
efforts de coprésidents du groupe de
minsk et je les dis de nouveau à mes
homologues arménien et azerbaïdjanais en
visite en turquie
le secrétaire général de l'otan a lui
aussi appelé à la fin des hostilités
entre les deux camps ankara de son côté
qui fait aussi partie du groupe de minsk
continue de prendre fait et cause pour
bakou oui a dit leekens nous sommes
profondément inquiet de l'escaladé
hostilités sous pli parties doivent
immédiatement cesser de se battre et
trouver une voie vers une résolution
pacifique
j'attends de la turquie qu'elle use de
son influence considérable pour calmer
les tensions
on n'ose à la sukuk tout le monde en
particulier l'otan devrait appeler
l'arménie à se retirer afin d'avoir une
solution à ce problème dans le cadre du
droit international et des résolutions
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
et de l'intégrité du territoire de
l'azerbaïdjan
il n'y a pas d'autre solution à ce
problème des iraniens et israéliens ont
également [ __ ] pour une résolution
pacifique à ce conflit
mais toutes ces voies internationales
n'ont toujours pas convaincu les deux
belligérants de déposer les armes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france sera alors pour commencer
des précisions sur le contexte pourquoi
les hostilités reprennent tel maintenant
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
on va il est probable que le président
de l'azerbaïdjan monsieur iduma lief a
considéré que finalement le moment était
propice
parce qu'il ya longtemps que verbale
j'en veux prendre sa revanche de
l'accord de cessez-le-feu de 1994 qui
avait été négocié sous les auspices et
avec la médiation de la russie après six
ans de conflit et 30000 morts donc et
qui avait coûté à peu près 13 % de son
territoire à la verveine gens alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est le terrain
serait favorable aujourd'hui pour
monsieur alief eh bien d'abord parce que
il a besoin de trouver une
diversion patriotique pour sa population
actuellement l'économie de l'azerbaïdjan
souffre de la baisse des prix du pétrole
l'économie ne va pas bien et
naturellement là comme ailleurs la crise
du coc vie 19 n'arrange pas les choses
donc il a pu mobiliser sa population
déjà que l'arménie a fait la même chose
au sens psychologique au sens propre les
deux les deux populations sont tout à
fait mobiliser alors l'azerbaïdjan a
saisi une autre opportunité c'est que
monsieur erdogan soutient à fond
l'azerbaïdjan est probablement
l'encouragent même à reprendre ce que
l'arménie a pu conquérir pendant la
guerre de 88 à 94
ça veut dire le la poche du nagorny
karabakh du haut karabakh dans laquelle
vivent
cent cinquante mille arméniens en
touraine en plein milieu du territoire
azéri mais les arméniens ont également
obtenu en 94 de d'avoir une zone tampon
tout autour qu'il contrôle pour assurer
la sécurité et diot du haut karabakh et
c'est cette zone tampon qui fait l'objet
naturellement de l'offensive de
l'azerbaïdjan qui voudraient récupérer
cette zone tampon
sinon le nagorny karabakh lui même est
ce que ce soir claude blanchemaison on
peut parler de guerre ouverte
oui parce que si on écoute les deux
parties on entend le premier ministre
arménien dire que cette terre est une
terre sacré pour l'arménie que c'est
donc une cause sacrée et qu'il faut se
battre et se battre jusqu'à la dernière
goutte de sang et puis du côté azéri
on invoque le droit international en
disant que l'azerbaïdjan veut recouvrer
le contrôle de l'intégrité de son
territoire à l'intérieur de ses
frontières et
on voit bien que la verve ajjan qui est
devenu puissant entre temps grâce à la
manne pétrolière au pétrole découvert en
mer caspienne n'entend pas baisser la
garde et céder aux injonctions
internationale il veut encore une fois
conquérir tout ou partie de ce qui a été
conquis en 94 par les arméniens et que
l'azerbaïdjan par avait dû accepter à
l'époque parce qu'il était en état de
faiblesse c'était d'ailleurs le père de
monsieur aliev qui était à l'époque le
président de l'azerbaïdjan et le fils
veut venger le père alors la france la
russie des états unis parlent qu'à
l'instant de menaces inacceptables pour
la stabilité de la région
elle les puissants extérieur quel rôle
ont-elles aujourd'hui d'abord la turquie
est clair que la turquie joue un rôle
déstabilisateur puisqu'elle encourage
manifestement l'azerbaïdjan dans cette
affaire dans cette opération militaire
et les propos qui sont tenus à ankara
sont les propos très guerrier la visite
de monsieur stoltenberg le
secrétaire-général de l'otan aujourd'hui
ne change pas grand chose parce que le
milieu des affaires étrangères très
calmement à 10 mais pour qui une
solution il faut que l'arménie se retire
complètement de notre territoire
il en est évidemment pas question et par
conséquent le combat va continuer alors
ceci avec quand même une réserve c'est
que l'azerbaïdjan n'a aucune intention
d'envahir le territoire de la république
d'arménie
parce que l'arménie en tant que telle
est liée par des accords de défense avec
la russie elle fait partie du traité de
sécurité
de coopération et d'autre part il ya une
base militaire russe en arménie par
conséquent d'affaires badjan ne touchera
pas à l'armée l'objectif de la barbade
gens c'est de récupérer la zone tampon
contrôlée par l'arménie autour du
nagorny karabakh et le nid gorny
karabakh lui même
évidemment ceci n'est pas possible et il
faut ouvrir la négociation négociations
qui n'a pas abouti depuis 22 ans
la france s'y étaient essayés en son
temps en tant que coprésident le groupe
de minsk et le président chirac lui même
avait tenté d'aider médiation entre le
président aliev le père et le président
arménien de l'époque pour conclure en
quelques mots aujourd'hui où la france
si su se situe-t-elle pardon dans le
dossier eh bien elle va jouer pleinement
son rôle en tant que président
coprésident le groupe de minsk avec la
russie avec les états unis
il est vrai que on voit bien dans la
presse française que la france et voit
plutôt d'un d'un d'un oeil favorable la
cause arménienne
peut-être parce qu'il ya une communauté
franco arménienne qui est assez
importante et que cette communauté joue
un rôle important dans la population
française peut-être aussi parce que la
force n'est jamais un moyen acceptable
pour régler un différend internationale
mais ceci étant je pense que la france
garde aussi les contacts avec toutes les
parties dans cette affaire merci
beaucoup claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales et bio
kyrgyzstan à présent au moins 16 blessés
à bichkek la capitale suite à des
manifestations liées à la proclamation
des résultats des élections législatives
un scrutin qui selon les derniers
résultats seraient en faveur des partis
soutenant le président plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant le siège du parlement
pour réclamer une nouvelle élection
qu'ils estiment frauduleuse
après quelques échauffourées les forces
de l'ordre ont dispersé la foule tout
tentaient d'envahir le siège du
gouvernement le chef de mission de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe estiment que le
scrutin dans l'ensemble s'est bien
déroulé les élections législatives du 4
octobre se sont déroulées dans le cadre
d'une législation à améliorer les droits
et libertés fondamentaux ont été
globalement respectée les allégations
crédibles d'achat de voix et d'abus de
ressources administratives
tous deux interdits par la loi ont été
les plus préoccupantes pour notre équipe
d'observateurs la direction les états
unis après son hospitalisation en raison
d'un test positif au co vite 19 donald
trump s'est voulu rassurant mais des
messages contradictoires ont semé le
trouble sur l'état de santé du locataire
de la maison blanche dans la
communication est remise en question n'a
déjà de layrac
quand on aime on ne compte pas les
risques non plus semble-t-il pour donald
je pense que nous allons faire une
petite surprise à ses formidables
patriotes qui sont dehors depuis
longtemps avec des drapeaux trump et qui
aime notre pays
quand je voi enthousiasme que sans doute
personne d'autre n'a jamais connu cet
enthousiasme de personnes qui aiment
notre travail
je me dis que j'ai droit à plus d'
enthousiasme que n'importe qui d'autre
est positif au kobus 19 hospitalisé
pendant plusieurs jours le président
américain n'a rien trouvé de mieux que
de sortir de l'hôpital militaire de
walter reed à près de washington et cela
pour saluer ses partisans massés devant
l'établissement
m
allah
une sortie qui a suscité de vives
critiques puisque jugé trop risqué pour
les agents de la protection du chef
d'état américain âgé de 74 ans il faut
que chaque personne présente dans le
véhicule pendant cette sortie
présidentielle complètement inutiles
soient placés en quarantaine pendant 14
jours ils peuvent tomber malades ils
peuvent mourir au du théâtre politique
un théâtre voulue par trump qui met leur
vie en danger
c'est de la folie l'irresponsabilité de
trump semble sans fin faire conduire ces
agents des services secrets avec un
patient covit 19 qui plus est avec des
fenêtres fermées les expose inutilement
à un risque d'infection
et pourquoi un coup de pub c'est honteux
ces agents risquent déjà leur vie chaque
jour un coup de pub en pleine campagne
électorale
rien de très étonnant à moins d'un mois
du scrutin présidentiel cette
contamination au kobus 19 pour est en
effet coûté sa réélection à donald trump
réélire à un candidat
inconscients du danger n'est pas
forcément la qualité première recherché
par les électeurs même si sa
personnalité atypique l'a mené à la
victoire en 2016 face à hillary clinton
depuis qu'il a été testé positif celui
qui est toujours locataire de la maison
blanche se veut rassurant je vais bien
je pense
merci à tous je vous aime après avoir
évoqué de légers symptômes
le médecin de la maison blanche a
finalement admis que l'état initial de
donald trump était plus grave que ceux
qui a officiellement été annoncée du
jeudi soir ou vendredi matin quand j'ai
quitté son chevet le président allait
bien avec seulement des symptômes bénins
et un taux d'oxygène proche de 100
vendredi soir quand je suis retourné à
son chevet il avait une forte fièvre et
sa saturation en oxygène était tombé
transitoirement au dessous de 94 % mag
pour le profane jusqu'à ce jour pourquoi
avez vous été aussi réticents à révéler
que le président avait reçu de l'oxygène
c'est une bonne question j'essayais de
refléter l'attitude optimiste de
l'équipe du président ainsi que
l'évolution de la maladie
je ne voulais donner aucune information
susceptible de laisser supposer que la
maladie aller dans une autre direction
et ce faisant nous avons essayé de
cacher quelque chose qui n'était pas
nécessairement avéré une communication
vous l'aurez compris brouillonne sur
l'état de santé de donald trump cette
contamination kobe 19 contrarie sa
stratégie qui consistait le plus
possible à passer sous silence sa
gestion de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui le président américain
semble avoir reçu une leçon qu'ils
qualifient d' intéressante
j'ai beaucoup appris sur le co vide je
l' ai appris en faisant l'expérience moi
même c'est l'école de la vie c'est pas
l'école dans les livres je les fais j'ai
compris c'est très intéressant je vous
expliquerai tout ça des explications
attendues au tournant par de nombreux
américains
elle les états unis pays le plus touché
du monde par le cos buts 19 comptabilise
plus de 7 millions 600 mille cas de
contamination et plus de 200000 morts
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis jacksonville avec kenneth
timerman l'ex conseiller aux affaires
étrangères de donald trump pour la
campagne 2016
[Musique]
kenneth timmerman bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
on vient de l'apprendre donald trump va
quitter l'hôpital dans un peu plus d'une
heure et demie son médecin doit
s'exprimer dans quelques minutes est ce
que la nouvelle est en train de se
répandre aux états unis
alors nous avons malheureusement un
problème de son nous avons
malheureusement un problème de son qu'on
va essayer de régler dans les quelques
secondes voilà kenneth timerman nous
avons un problème de sont ici on va
réessayer de de vous avoir en effet
puisqu'on vient d'apprendre il ya
quelques minutes que le président
américain donald trump et bien sortirait
de l'hôpital sont médecins doivent
s'exprimer d'ici quelques minutes on va
essayer de retrouver pour en parler
kenneth timerman qui est avec nous en
direct depuis jacksonville aux états
unis alors qu'il n'est timerman une
réaction peut-être à cette annonce le
président américain donald trump qui
doit quitter l'hôpital dans un peu plus
d'une heure et demie est ce que la
nouvelle est en train de se répandre aux
états unis
nous attendons la confirmation finale
nous a trompés écoute son docteur très
compétent a doctor demande reuter le
docteur khalit il ya beaucoup de
critiques du président mais les gens ne
comprend pas ce qui se passe aux etats
unis tout d'abord les services secrets
ont un devoir qui est de risquer leur
vie pour le président si quelqu'un
essayait par exemple de l'assassiner ils
sont prêts à prendre une balle pour le
président donc être dans une voiture
avec le président c'est tout à fait dans
leurs devoirs
mais l'opinion est extrêmement partisane
dans ce pays bien plus que je ne vais
jamais vu auparavant
bien plus que pendant l'ère bush les
gens sont habités par ce qu'on appelle
le syndrome de dérangement trump c'est à
dire qu'ils ont perdu toute trace youn
alité alors le président américain qui
vient à l'instant de
deux tweeté et sur les réseaux sociaux
il écrit n'ayez pas peur du coc vide
alors est ce que ça veut dire au fond
qu'il gare à garder son cap sur le
regard qu'il a sur cette épidémie
j'ai passé quatre mois et demi en france
lors du confinement volontaire je me
suis volontairement confiné chez moi
dans le sud de la france et pour moi
c'était pathétique c'était ridicule
c'était une violation de la liberté
individuelle et beaucoup de personnes
aux états unis pensent la même chose
les individus doivent prendre leur
responsabilité personnelle
le président a sa responsabilité
personnelle
il y a des consignes qui nous sont
transmises par les autorités médicales
les gens les respectent
ils essaient de maintenir la
distanciation physique et s'ils le
souhaitent ou lorsqu'il le faut ils
portent un masque mais le reste est
absurde
il faudrait que l'on vive à effrayer
d'un virus qui vient de chine qui a sans
aucun doute été répandues par le parti
communiste chinois
volontairement je pense que c'est
absurde je pense que c'est pathétique
nous sommes des adultes
nous avons survécu à la grippe espagnole
nous avons survécu à la grippe aux états
unis trois personnes trois fois plus de
personnes meurent du cancer
deux fois plus de personnes meurent de
cancer des poumons et pourtant on ne dit
pas aux gens d'arrêter de fumer chez eux
je pense que c'est une hystérie
déplorable qui a pris le pays
aujourd'hui
alors revenons à la communication sur
l'état de santé de deux dalles trump ces
derniers jours est-ce qu'elle n'a pas
été un peu brouillonne
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
messages tantôt optimistes et puis des
messages
ensuite un peu plus pessimistes qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
comment vous le comprenez ce que cela
révèle c'est que le président et son
équipe comme unique
à la seconde avec le peuple américain
lorsque le président a été s'est rendu à
l'hôpital
il ne se sentait pas bien ne sais pas
jusqu'à quel point la situation était
dangereuse on attendait de savoir s'il
allait se remettre rapidement ou pas il
a très bien réagi au traitement c'est ce
que les docteurs ont annoncé et ce que
l'on a pu constater c'est que les médias
américains
jouer des vidéos de marque ma dose la
première nuit que donald trump a passés
à l'hôpital lorsque rien n'était certain
et on fait passer cette vidéo 24 heures
après après que donald trump et
commencer à bien réagir traitement donc
pour moi c'est malhonnête
les médias sont manuels aux états unis
et d'ailleurs les médias français ne
sont pas mieux et je pense que votre
public comprend cela tout à fait alors
outre l'impact sur la campagne
présidentielle
quel impact cette séquence peut avoir
sur le candidat trump je ne suis rendue
à plusieurs rallyes de donald trump
j'ai pu constater l'enthousiasmé
extraordinaire des quantités des
partisans de donald trump
c'est vraiment une force extraordinaire
dont dispose donald trump
il a réussi à galvaniser le peuple
américain les pousser à s'exprimer et
j'espère que le président continuera à
avoir des rallyes en personne il y aura
beaucoup de pression contre ceux là les
démocrates vont résister joe biden vous
aurez de la chance s'il essayait
d'organiser un rallye d'avoir une
centaine de personnes présente parce
qu'il n'y a pas autant d'enthousiasmé
populaire pour joe biden que pour donald
trump le peuple n donald trump
c'est une chose que je n'avais jamais vu
auparavant cet homme a abandonné
fille d'un milliardaire il a abandonné
son appartement doré pour recevoir les
flèches les insultes qu'il a reçu au
cours des quatre dernières années pour
le peuple américain le peuple américain
comprend cela et en ce qui concerne la
campagne tant que le président est
malade
est-ce que selon vous il va être
inattaquable pour ses adversaires
ou alors au contraire les hostilités
vont continuer mais finalement je baille
tonnes a dit qu'il allait faire une
pause pour les publicités de campagne
contre donald trump mais elles ont
continué nous sommes en pleine campagne
politique c'est la saison politique il y
a encore beaucoup de choses qui nous
attendent avant les élections mais une
chose est certaine ne connaîtront pas le
résultat des élections présidentielles
le 3 novembre
c'est un gros problème c'est ce sur quoi
compte les démocrates c'est ce sur quoi
repose leur plan de campagne
ils veulent instaurer la confusion
retarder le résultat qui pourrait
arriver deux à trois semaines après le 3
novembre
d'ailleurs kamala harris la candidate à
la vice présidente est une éminence
grise est très doué à ce genre de jeu en
2010 et gagné 2 à perdre et de 3%
le jour des élections et quelques
semaines plus tard elle gagné 2 1% après
que beaucoup d'innombrables bulletin
était décompté par ses partisans dans
les bureaux de vote
et c'est ce genre de stratégie que les
démocrates essaient d'appliquer encore
une fois pour conclure vous qui
connaissez bien
donald trump à ce que le fait d'avoir
contracté la maladie selon vous eh bien
le président américain va va changer un
peu de regards et peut-être prendre
davantage de mesures voire d'autres
mesures
concernant l'épidémie le président a
déjà expliqué dans une vidéo filmée à
l'hôpital qu'il apprend beaucoup de
choses sur le gorna virus à l'hôpital
qu'il prend la chose très au sérieux et
je pense qu'il va appliquer ces leçons à
la campagne je pense qu'il a tout de
suite compris que les traitements
peuvent avoir des résultats
une miraculeuse nous avons beaucoup de
traitements disponibles pour traiter la
maladie pour traiter les symptômes pour
l'endiguer et ses traitements doivent
être mises à la disposition à des gens
de manière très large et je pense que
c'est ce que va dire le président autre
chose qui pourrait dire est que la vie
est dangereuse on ne peut pas vivre en
tant qu'être humain dans ce monde sans
prendre de risques
les gens doivent évaluer ce risque le
président l'a fait il a mené campagne
avant d'avoir attrapé le coronavirus
sans doute qui lui continuera nous
devons tous prendre nos propres
responsabilités et évaluer les risques
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire c'est
permettre l'apparition d'un état
nourrissent thann et à maman qui nous
dictent notre conduite
à chaque seconde de notre vie qui nous
dicte nos responsabilités et je pense
que ce sera le message du précédent à
l'avenir merci beaucoup canal timerman
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes un ex conseiller
aux affaires étrangères de donald trump
pour la campagne 2016 restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur les nouvelles mesures restrictives
face au co vide et qui entre en vigueur
ce mardi dans les zones d' alerte
maximale comme à paris puis nous
parlerons de l'enseignement de l'arabe à
l'école le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin plaide pour son
renforcement dans le cadre laïc dans un
cadre laïc et républicain un moyen de
lutter contre le séparatisme on
s'interroge ce sera l'objet
notre face à face à rester avec nous sur
rtl france
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire la france allait
voir c'est un cycle de polichinelle je
ne crois pas qu'il appartient la france
des ligues des problèmes entre ivoiriens
le bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train de briller leurs prêts plus il
faut demander au régime ivoiris
référence sorte d n'est pas crisper
davantage les positions la tension est
déjà trop lourd vous demandé un report
des scrutins prévus le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
c'est voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 5 octobre 2001 de nouvelles
mesures restrictives pour deux semaines
avec la fermeture des bars clubs de
sport ici nous bien encore les
universités contrainte de limiter leur
capacité d'accueil à paris et la proche
banlieue sont passés en état d' alerte
maximale depuis hier soir les
restaurants en revanche peuvent rester
ouverts dans la capitale avec un
protocole sanitaire renforcée ceux de la
région de marseille sont rouverts
elle a cité phocéenne va d'ailleurs se
doter de son propre conseil scientifique
pour évaluer la situation sanitaire
un renforcement de l'apprentissage de
l'arabe à l'école le ministre de
l'intérieur plaide en faveur de cette
proposition dans une interview accordée
à nos confrères du journal du dimanche
est la cinquième langue la plus parlée
dans le monde est enseigné avant tout
dans les mosquées explique gérald
darmanin enseigner l'arabe à l'école
dans un cadre républicain et laïc alors
est-ce un bon moyen d'enrayer le
séparatisme de réduire le pouvoir des
religieux ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face
[Musique]
l'ombre envisage un durcissement de sa
politique migratoire et le renvoi de
plus de migrants venus illégalement une
déclaration d'un ministre britannique de
l'intérieur priti patel ce dimanche
alors que le royaume uni est confronté à
un nombre record de tentative de
traversée de la manche depuis la france
et la ministre se réjouit avec le bric
site
le gouvernement pourra décider je cite
pour la première fois depuis des
décennies qui rentre et sort de notre
pays au chili et la population se
prononcera le 25 octobre prochain sur le
processus de révision constitutionnelle
à référendum pour déterminer s'il faut
changer la constitution héritée de la
dictature d'augusto pinochet
la consultation devait avoir lieu le 26
avril dernier mais a dû être reporté en
raison du coc vite 19
et on débute avec l'actualité du jour en
france dominée par les nouvelles mesures
de restriction pour paris et sa petite
couronne on le rappelle placées en zones
d'alerté maximale le préfet de police de
paris didier lallement et la maire de
paris anne hidalgo ont tenu à midi une
conférence de presse les bars seront
fermés les restaurants dont l'activité
principale est la vente d'alimentation
pourront rester ouverts ais les piscines
également fermé mais accessible aux
mineurs
tous les équipements de plein air
pourront rester ouverts à condition de
rassembler moins de 1000 personnes ou
50% de leur capacité maximale
les centres commerciaux pourront
accueillir au maximum un client pour
quatre mètres carrés de des visites
peuvent se faire sur rendez-vous dans
les ehpad et dans les universités la
capacité d'accueil est réduite à 50% et
du côté de la situation sanitaire selon
les derniers chiffres de santé publique
france on dénombre 5084 nouvelles
contaminations aux copies de 19 ans 24
heures soixante dix personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital et 1409 patients
sont actuellement réalisation que le
taux de positivité des tests continuent
d'augmenter et atteint 8,6 pour cent
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandra aurions code généticienne
ancienne directrice de recherche à
l'inserm
alexandra orio conde bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors pour commencer on l'a vu un des
nouveaux cas de contamination a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'elle différence au fond
entre les cas positifs au co vides et
les malades du comité ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est bien qu'on commençait
par cette question parce qu'en fait
toutes les mesures que vous venez de
décrire sont essentiellement fondée sur
ce paramètre et ce paramètre
il vous l'avez probablement compris il
est il indique sur la positivité à une
pcr le moka est dévoyée parce que ça ne
correspond pas enfin dans l'est
imaginaire des scientifiques et des
médecins normalement un cas c'est un
malade
on sait qu' il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre le fait que vous soyez testés
positifs et que vous créiez des
symptômes du cofide donc on voit là
qu'on est en train de prendre toutes ses
décisions sur un un problème de
positivité de 2 pc à ce qui évidemment
est dérangeant soit 62% des personnes
positives on peut vite 19 n'aurait pas
de symptômes
donc des porteurs sains donc mais
contagieux c'est avec cette réalité clos
port du masque prend tout son sens vous
aimeriez vous citez vous même le fait
que la lorsqu'on est positif on va avoir
entre voilà cinquante pour 60% certains
disent 90% de chances de ne pas être
porteur de moindre symptôme
donc on est en train de parler de cas
quand finalement la majorité ressemble
vous avez dit 62% certains 10,90
qu'importe n'allons pas dans les
chiffres la majorité est véritablement
sans symptôme donc sans qu vide
il ya plusieurs raisons à cela c'est
qu'en fait on demande à ce test de nous
renseigner sur ce qui ne peut pas faire
c'est à dire la contagiosité ce test il
peut juste dire ce qu'il ya des
présences delà du disque dur on va dire
de dudu du virus alors ça va évidemment
par exemple si jamais je je je je touche
qu'elle un malade et que je mets le
doigt dans le nez avec l'onf et la pca
sur mes doigts on va retrouver que mes
doigts sont positifs vous comprenez
c'est donc viser un véritablement une
circulation mais qui ne correspond pas
donc une circulation
des séquences du lyrisme et qui
correspond pas au virus mais est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'on m'avait moyen de
mesurer la contagiosité
aujourd'hui on aurait des moyens de le
faire on ne le fait pas c'est un point
crucial
par exemple il suffirait déjà pour avoir
ne serait-ce qu'une idée c'est de mettre
en place un observatoire sur les
transmissions secondaires d'un alors on
va dire je suis cas positifs
et puis il faudrait regarder si les
mécas contacts vont eux mêmes être
positif et avoir un observatoire pour
suivre très précisément si c'était juste
des positifs ou si c'était des positive
avec symptômes
or à aucun moment on dit mais il
faudrait que décrivez nouveau symptôme
est ce que vous avez de là tout est ce
que vous avez d écoulement nasal est ce
que tous aient tous ces points qui vont
[Musique]
engendrer une contagiosité évidemment
alors en termes de létalité la grippe et
le co vides sont finalement des
pourcentages très proches et vous nous
le disiez sur cette antenne mi-septembre
l'académie de pharmacie réclame le
vaccin contre la grippe avec comme
priorité les personnes fragiles
il est personnel soignant c'est la
première des choses à faire aujourd'hui
la première des choses à faire je
voulais dire effectivement sur cette
antenne ya quelque temps je vous le
redis avec encore plus d'acuité parce
qu'une étude vient de sortir montrant
que dans 39 pays
si on regarde le nombre de morts 2 co
vide dans ces pays ainsi que la
vaccination des plus de 65 ans moi qui
lie à une association positive c'est à
dire quoi ça veut dire que
les endroits où il ya eu plus de
vaccination des plus de 65 ans et là où
il ya eu le plus de morts de qu'ovide 19
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut pas dire
à sa veillée
il faut impérativement discuter ce point
que j'apporte depuis quelques mois
basée sur des études dont je vous avais
parlé la dernière fois mais l'a appuyé
sur encore d'autres études avant toute
chose donc faisons un point pour une
fois la prude la médecine vous savez le
son symbole c'est le miroir est en haut
de ce bâton et de ce serpent est le
miroir c'est en fait la prudence et la
prudence c'est prendre de bonnes
décisions
c'est tout ce qu'on a pas réussi à faire
jusqu'à présent
si on pouvait prendre là cette fois ci
la bonne décision non pas sur des
habitudes de ce qu'on attend est ce
qu'on est en droit d'attendre d'une
vaccination contre la grippe
je pense que pour une fois on fait les
choses dans l'ordre ça me semble
fondamental alors il nous reste quelques
secondes juste peut-être cette dernière
question au niveau de la recherche
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui de la
molécule prometteuse de l'institut
pasteur de lille
on n'en sait pas grand chose à la mesure
de leur communication qui est encore
très restreinte et on comprend pourquoi
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est le principe le principe de cette
découverte entre guillemets découverte
c'est cette société aptus à constituer
une banque de 2000 médicaments et et
passent en boucle c'est différentes
médicaments qu'ils appellent molécule
mais qui sont finalement qui ont déjà
été avec une autorisation de mise sur le
marché c'est pour cela que ça peut aller
très vite et donc passe notamment
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et d'autres
molécules d'autres médicaments
et retrouver un ancien médicament de
parmi ces 2000 qui serait prometteur je
n'en sais pas plus
actuellement je sais simplement que
j'espère qu'ils ont comparées par
rapport à l'asie trop me final à ces
macrolides qui ont quand même donné
tellement de d'effets bénéfiques et
d'après les remontées qu'on peut en
avoir et on a un beau coup de remonter
de généralistes qui ont mis leur
patience aux antibiotiques et zinc et
avec une volonté très positive
merci beaucoup alexandra aurions code
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes généticienne et ancienne directrice
de recherche à l'inserm est toujours en
france dans le sillage du discours d'
emmanuel macron sur le séparatisme aux
mureaux vendredi dernier le ministre de
l'intérieur plaide pour un renforcement
de l'apprentissage de l'arabe à l'école
dans les colonnes dans les colonnes de
nos confrères du journal du dimanche et
gérald darmanin indique vouloir
renforcer l'apprentissage de la
cinquième langue la plus parlée dans le
monde au sein des écoles qui alors
qu'elle est surtout enseigné dans les
mosquées précise le ministre il prône
ainsi un cadre républicain et laïc alors
enseigner l'arabe l école est ce un bon
moyen pour lutter contre le séparatisme
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir bonsoir à vos côtés
gab alabina cofondateur du mouvement des
droits civiques bonsoir alors gérald
darmanin on le disait de renforcer
l'apprentissage de l'arabe à l'école une
proposition républicaine et courageuse
affirme le ministre de l'intérieur vous
partager son opinion à mal gaby n'a
c'est une bonne proposition
oui c'est une excellente proposition
simplement parce que d'abord l'ignorance
c'est une terrot de la radicalisation et
que lorsqu'on apprend l'arabe dans la
langue et dans l'esprit on à la société
d'apprendre la civilisation arabo
musulmane pour être précis jusqu'à la
plupart des magasins sont plutôt de
civilisation arabo-musulmane et cet
apprentissage permettre effectivement
donner un éclairage nouveau
alors culture qui ne connaissent que
très peu et permettrait surtout de tes
tristes et un petit peu les tensions et
de sortir des de la proximité cas alors
florian philippot l'arabe est déjà une
langue vivante a enseigné à l'école d'el
ses mandants la preuve dans le programme
de l'éducation nationale finalement
accentuer cette proposition
effectivement est ce que cela peut
éviter aux jeunes d'aller apprendre
l'arabe à la mosquée ou dans des écoles
coraniques et puis avec un enseignement
ou non mais dans le contexte également
de la culture quel est votre regard sur
cette proposition florian philippot non
j'y suis très favorable je pense que
c'est très étonnant de partir dans un
débat sur le séparatisme soi disant pour
lutter contre le séparatisme en
commençant par justement une mesure qui
sépare enfin ce qui unit c'est la langue
nationale si vous voulez si on veut que
ces jeunes qui qui sont issus de
l'immigration dans les parents est issu
d'une migration soit la nation française
il faut leur apprendre le français
et on sait que c'est la langue nationale
et on sait que français malheureusement
est de moins en moins bien écrit et
parlé
quelques problèmes à l'école à l'école
primaire il faut donc mettre le paquet
beaucoup plus sur le français ça me
semble être la priorité absolue pour
tous les jeunes et les enfants de france
en quelle que soit leur origine
évidemment et c'est comme ça que nous
facilitera l'intégration et
l'assimilation la langue arabe
c'est une langue d'importance et d'une
culture qui doit être apprise en france
comme peut l'être le japonais le persan
le chinois ou d'autres uniquement à
partir du
secondaire je le pense mais je pense que
ce serait parfaitement contreproductif
vous savez les religieux trouveraient
toujours où les radicaux d'autres
prétextes pour avoir accès à ces jeunes
si ce n'est pas la 30e' sage de l'arabe
ils me diront que c'est
l'approfondissement de l'apprentissage
de l'arabe où ils trouveront bien autre
chose ça n'est pas du tout la réponse
adéquate à l'orgue amalgamer n'a
effectivement qu'est ce que vous
répondez à florian philippot qui nous
dit ben mettons le paquet sur ce que sur
ce qui unit aujourd'hui à l'école à
savoir la langue française quelle est
votre réponse par un concert très simple
d'abord c'est la promotion de la ddt de
la culture depuis quand le fait
d'apprendre plusieurs langues et réduit
la qualité d'apprendre une langue ça n'a
aucun sens j'ai envie de dire à monsieur
philippe ont conduit souvent nos
ancêtres les gaulois décoratifs même au
niveau des postes colonisés mais que le
gaulois à propos paraît sept langues
anciennes
nous on l'a récupéré que sans mordant le
français alors que l'arabe à mille mots
je préfère la lys abricots bananes et
autres mais bon quoi qu'il en soit déjà
le français est déjà tâté arabité
culturellement et c'est normal c'est
françois 1er qui avait ouvert la porte à
cette voie c'est surtout la présence
arabe en espagne et dans toute la france
à narbonne pour une centaine d'années
mais au delà de ça c'est surtout la
langue du commerce à l'époque et je suis
très étonné que vous ne parliez pas de
l'anglais par exemple ça sent le moins
voudra-t-il vous poser de problème de
vous dire que peut-être l'anglais est
trop parler d'école ça c'est pas un
problème puisque c'est une culture
occidentale peut-être et puis je ne vois
pas en quoi - prendrait mieux que
puissent apprendre
évidemment qu'il faut que les gens
parlent bien le français et c'est une
défaillance du système scolaire actuel
qui fait qu'il ya des écoles de 800 à
oreille casse henry cap par exemple vous
allez gecol devant lui qu'il s'ouvre ont
souvent sur des écoles de seconde zone
on apprend plus grand-chose même pas le
français mais au delà du français puis
surtout je suis étonné parce que
l'apprentissage des premières langues
dans la prime enfance c'est le meilleur
moyen d'accéder à la langue et la
culture
je ne sais pas si vous parlez l'anglais
moi j'ai la chance parieurs anglais de
connaître lire et écrire l'arabe c'est
un parcours du combattant mais c'est pas
l'école derrière lui qui m'a donné cette
chance âge les prix ailleurs il a fallu
que passe par des mosquées la mosquée de
paris en récurrence il a fallu que j'ai
la chance une fois dans l'école d'art
est lui d'avoir un directeur d'air je
salue monsieur cochet qui a eu
l'intelligence de nous donner des cours
d'arabe à l'école de la république
j'étais petit j'avais 12 ans c'est comme
ça que j'appuyais culture la richesse de
parler plusieurs langues permet d'ouvrir
les esprits
et quand on ouvre à l'esprit est bien on
est beaucoup moins perméable à désirer
radical il est difficile de
que vous fassiez la promotion du
manquement de connaissances en matière
de de la connaissance de plusieurs
langues il ya le français d'apprendre
étrangères parle que l'onglet quasiment
aucune langue étrangère
et moi je pense qu'il faut faire la
promotion je suis étonné de ce que l'on
dit la flore ayant fini peau non je
crois que vous confondez tout moi je
suis très favorable à ce qu'on apprenne
des langues étrangères je suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on aurait apprennent
les langues dites mortes comme le latin
ou le grec qui s'ils ont été
complètement abandonné et je suis y
compris favrat parce que les gens qui
veulent apprendre un peu plus âgé de la
ram le russe le chinois sera puisse le
faire mais je pense que ça n'est pas le
lieu de l'école primaire
vous savez les horaires tout simplement
pour vous répondre ne sont pas
extensibles si vous mettez une heure ou
deux heures par semaine d' arabes
vous allez enlever une heure ou deux
heures ailleurs parce que les enfants
voient là ont des horaires évidemment et
leurs enseignants aussi or il faut
mettre le paquet sur le français à
l'école primaire parce que quand on a
entre 6 et 10 ans c'est là qu'on doit
apprendre parfaitement à maîtriser sa
langue à l'écrit comme à l'oral est la
langue de la république la langue
française c'est le français c'est comme
ça et je crois que c'est comme cela
qu'on fera une nation ne fait pas
semblant que ne parler simplement de
l'apprentissage des langues moi je parle
anglais je parle allemand je suis ravi
de parler ces langues et j'encourage
tout le monde à apprendre les langues
étrangères
et vous avez raison sur un point la
sueur focalisation sur l'anglo américain
est un problème et je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on apprend on sur
apprennent l'anglo-américain à l'école
primaire certainement pas je pense qu'il
faut se concentrer sur le français mais
là on voit bien que le risque c'est la
dérive communautariste c'est quoi certes
un peu apprendront la rade parce que ils
sont d'origine arabe ou parce que leurs
parents le sont et on va renforcer le
séparatisme la ghettoïsation et je pense
que c'est tout à fait l'inversé de ce
qu'il faut faire
alors gare à la voilà à nouveau ajourné
à les y voilà donc déjà je ne confonds
pas tous une capacité à pékin qui permet
de partir beaucoup pensent que vous
dites est surtout due au fait que ceux
de vous ramener un petit peu à quelques
réalités je vous dis qu'est la prime
enfance permet d'assimiler mieux les
lampes à la longue les lans on ne semble
pas que quand on leur fait en sorte de
l'as 2 de la loi dire du cp cm1 il sait
pas parler français le sait après
l'amélioration des qualités en terme de
maîtrise de la langue se perd à partir
de la sixième et la troisième dans les
établissements de seconde zone et vous
les connaissez très bien je prétends que
sertic quand on rentre à henri iv on n'a
pas de problème de langue vous le savez
très bien parce qu'on est à paris moi
j'ai eu la chance d'être à l'école à
paris ça fait une différence mais je
sais ce que c'est que l'école dans l'est
cousins et cousines ont subi l'école des
banlieues je parle de la banlieue est
républicaine
vous confondez vous en revanche le fait
d'avoir de la culture et d'élargir sa
culture avec un esprit beaucoup plus
flexible sur le colza l'allemand jeu
procure article on n'a pas retenu la
langue dit claire on a retenu la langue
de goethe
je pense que je vous reprocherai jamais
de parler allemand parce qu'à mon sens
c'est une très belle langue à wisches
qui a nourri d'anglais chaos nourrir
français aussi falloir donc ça c'est une
chose et deuxième chose concernant
l'apprentissage
évidemment que c'est l'enfance qui doit
la prendre en main défaut en france et
qu'on apprend sur le tard des lampes on
ne maîtrise pas j'ai pas vu je vais pas
vous expliquer à quel point les français
quand il compte à l'étranger se couvre
de ridicule quand il articule par louis
de trois mots d'anglais d'espagnol de
français
la france est plus ou moins approximatif
mais plus j'en parle pas l'espagnol et
l'anglais
donc tout ça pour vous dire que il faut
sortir dessus par annick mais qui
consiste à dire le français domine c'est
fini le français qui était une langue
comme la rate d'ailleurs au demeurant
une langue de diplomatie on a conservé
sa valeur à l'onu pour la décoration
le français est en perte de vitesse
parce que naturellement et c'est comme
ça c'est le jeu de puissance économique
c'est l'état unique de nous bientôt les
états unis seront perdus vitesse parce
que ce sera le mandarin chinois qui l'a
dominé mais quoi qu'il en soit on coule
et les paradis dire que la cinquième
langue la plus parlée au monde qui en
plus à un vecteur religieux comme vous
parliez du latin tout à leurs vecteurs
religieux de catholicisme et du fils yen
l'euro perd et bien l'arabe secteur
religieux l'islam mais on a 2 6 1 on al
islam éclairé qui réfléchit qui s'ouvre
celui de tales kindy celui de blé
connexes on sent qu'ils ont été latinisé
pour tous quand on parle de la vie saine
quand on regarde averroès rouge et de
sina en art à tout comme quand on parle
des extraits n'orientent orientaux du
type on parle souvent par exemple
confucius c'est pas son nom son vrai nom
chinois n'est pas conçu ce vous avez été
chercher ça c'est une façon de se
réapproprier la culture orientale qui
plaisait aux orientalistes et d'oublier
que les gens ne se grandissent que
lorsqu'ils ont enfin réapproprier tous
leurs aspects culturels qui sont
multiples et variées et c'est en ça je
vous dis qu'effectivement la défaillance
du système français c'est pas d'avoir
deux ans depuis arabe ou d'anglais ou
d'espagnol en primaire c'est de ne pas
les avoir si florian philippot vous
répondez tout de suite juste avant vous
à vous montrer la déclaration de gérald
darmanin ce week-end dans le journal du
dimanche à propos de cet enseignement à
l'école regarder alors l'enseigné à
l'école c'est aussi réduire le pouvoir
des religieux
voilà ça vient voilà lancés à l'école
c'est aussi le pouvoir de réduire pardon
pouvoir des religieux comment vous le
comprenez florian philippot oui j'avais
entendu cet argument j ai répondu dans
la première intervention pense que c'est
une c'est une bêtise parce que les
religieux ceux qui veulent endoctrinés
des jeunes le front le trouveront
toujours un prétexte à un prétexte par
la langue ou par un autre aspect le
sport n'importe quoi il faut vont
toujours un moyen je pense que c'est pas
du tout un argument valable pour vous
répondre
vous êtes dans une logique
multiculturaliste en fait vous dites
voilà qu'un enfant doit connaître tous
les aspects de sa culture
y compris quand en fait il n'a vécu
qu'en france donc en fait vous l'empêché
de pouvoir s'assimiler à la nation
française
vous allez le ghettoïser vous allez le
force l'assigné à résidence culturel en
quelque sorte y compris à un pays qui ne
la donnent à une civilisation qui est
tout à fait respectable mais qui n'a
actuellement pas reconnu et peut-être
même pas ses parents et est alors vous
allez l'empêché d'être parfaitement
intégré la france en parlant le français
et vous dites que le français la langue
française est maîtrisée à l'école
malheureusement non et on le sait
qu'elle l'est de moins en mois il faut
donc mettre le paquet et je le redis sur
le français la moitié de la 30e' sage je
crois à l'école primaire devrait se
faire aujourd'hui
d'abord et avant tout sur le français à
l'oral et à l'écrit parce qu'il est très
mal au moins en moins bien le maîtriser
et c'est là que celui que naissent les
principales inégalités sociales
aujourd'hui c'est dans la maîtrise de la
langue nationale entre un cv bien rédigé
en français et un cv mal rédigée parce
que la langue n'a pas été de maîtriser
et bien l'employeur choisira le bon
serré et donc vous allez creuser les
perpétuer les inégalités sociales il
faut absolument mettre le paquet ça
n'empêche pas l'apprentissage des
langues étrangères c'est un autre débat
l'ouverture sur la conti sage des
civilisations des langues étrangères des
langues mortes etc
c'est un autre débat il faut
l'encourager mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que propose darmana et est ce
que vous dites également en filigrane
gamin labine à regarder également le
voilà répondait peut-être avant on va
écouter le commentaire des manuels
macron à ce sujet vous répondez juste
après donc le commentaire des manuels
macron à ce sujet nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes c'est le
coeur du sujet les jeunes vont apprendre
l'arabe dans des associations qui leur
propose le pire est qu'ils sont
manipulés le séparatisme islamique pur
il cela mist pointé du doigt par
emmanuel macron celle au coeur du sujet
explique le président il a raison gamme
à la villa et rapidement juste pour
remettre les pendules à l'heure le
multiculturalisme n'est pas une insulte
c'est une richesse si vous préférez être
réduits vous parler trois langues
ça m'étonne de vous à ne paraît qu'une
seule langue c'est très surprenante et
juste pour votre information le chômage
qui touche les banlieues 40% 5 1%
toujours les banlieues ça n'est pas
parce qu'ils maîtrisent pas le français
puisque souvent des gens très qualifiés
n'ont pas accès à l'emploi c'est parce
qu'il ya un problème road qui s'appelle
plus le sectarisme raciste tout
simplement
et ça c'est un problème doit être réglé
en profondeur à savoir comment varier
d'intégration génial insertion sociale
comment laisser des gens qui
travaillaient on le voit bien avec le
beurre les jeunes de banlieue sont
précipités par une loi qui leur était
ouverte
le travail ensuite concernant le fait de
parler plusieurs langues c'est une
richesse qui vous permet par exemple
d'aller à dubaï ça veut dire tout bête
mais tous ceux qui partent à dubaï qui
parle un peu l'arabe aujourd'hui sont
libérés de ces questions du chômage donc
le poids n'est pas de savoir si on doit
pas connaître puis tu retournes origine
on doit connaître plusieurs cultures et
je suis multiculturaliste et fier de
l'être parce que c'est une richesse vous
vous réduisez à une seule futur c'est
bien triste
bien que riche cette culture elle n'est
pas la culture centrales du monde et
c'est normal puisqu'elle a fait son
temps chaque culture fait son temps et
s'agrège à d'autres cultures et c'est
pas un problème d'expression orale
voyage maîtrise parfaitement français
sinon mieux que vous et pour autant j'ai
pas trouvé de travail
j'ai créé mon entreprise parce que je
sais ce que c'est l'exclusion concernant
le séparatisme islami dont le sumac on
parle alors c'est dépose effets de
manche très mignon le deuxième essai de
façon de ne pas parler des trois points
qui fâchent aujourd'hui on a une
détresse économique qui est très
puissant très marqué on va dire ce qui
se passe avec les bars et les
restaurants on voit aussi qu'il ya aussi
une non maîtrise de cette crise
sanitaire qui fait paniquer tout le
monde littéralement parce que maintenant
les états majors ne sont plus en mesure
de pouvoir y répondre il suffit de voir
l'état dans lequel sont les états unis
et la france à proportion égale et dans
les bêtas et pour finir ce séparatisme
et amis qui permet une fois de plus
cette fois ci tu quoque émissaires de
montrer du doigt autre chose pour pas
montrer les traits des problèmes et les
gilet jaune ne s'y sont pas trompé
lorsqu'il manifester parce qu'ils ont
bien compris que la question des
banlieues était marginal par rapport à
leur propre problématique et et social
florian philippot le mot de la fin pour
conclure
bah vous savez y en a pas suffisamment
d'emplois à dubai pour tout le monde
donc longtemps essayé d'avoir raison
toile ici et je maintiens que le souvent
le problème de l'accès à l'emploi
s'étend
on maîtrise du français là vous vous
trompez où vous voulez tromper
littéralement les gens et quant à vos
considérations sur la culture française
qui serait donc terminés ou en voie
d'être l'envoi des réactions je ne suis
pas du tout d'accord avec vous c'est une
très grande culture une très belle
culture et j'aimerais que les français
quelles que soient leurs origines
connaissent beaucoup mieux l'étendue
magnifique de notre culture de nos arts
de notre littérature de notre théâtre et
de tout ce qui fait la richesse de notre
pays
mais je moi je suis très attaché à ce
que nous soyons fiers et formions notre
culture française vous vous êtes
d'accord avec macron pour dire que la
culture française n'existe pas c'est
votre droit mais pèse de multiples enfin
la liste suivante êtes vous avez à la
fin quand on est multiculturelle il ya
plus futur voilà on ne maîtrise rien du
tout on sautille de culture en culture
et on n'a pas de culture et on se
retrouve en bourg b englobé dans le
mondialisme avec sa langue et sa langue
se sera pas l'arabe ce sera l'anglo
américain je vous l'annonçais de tout de
suite donc je pense que ce soit ce que
vous dites est profondément naïf soit
vous dissimuler votre jeu mais il est
évident que va apprendre l'arabe aux
enfants d'origine étrangère ou dont les
parents étaient d'origine étrangère est
allé à l'école est un moyen de séparer
le cas c'est le pays d' empêcher
l'intégration et l'assimilation de faire
avancer au contraire l'islamisme le
croit à la fin et le séparatisme
le communautarisme et non pas de faire
une nation et est de permettre à la
france d'être unis c'est une évidence
pour moi la langue c'est le ciment
premier d'une nation et c'est pour cela
que la langue française est tellement
attaqué y compris par les
communautaristes les séparatistes que
vous avez représenté ce soir dans le
débat merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté le jeu du débat merci à vous
florian philippot je rappelle que vous
êtes président des patriotes merci à
vous amalgame dynaco fondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques est resté
avec nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la politique
migratoire au royaume uni la ministre de
l'intérieur
ribatel prévoit un durcissement des
règles d'entrée sur le territoire puis
direction le chili le 25 octobre
prochain les électeurs se prononceront
sur la révision de la constitution a
tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui j'ai amadou gon pour
le valais est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession il estimant que le
président ouattara est celui qui a le
leadership nécessaire pour faire face au
public se pose à nous tant au niveau
interne ou externe climat particulier en
ce moment en côte d'ivoire et des
violences sous prétexte dont une
manifestation et d'expression du droit
démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
et
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en bougeant par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur hertz les
francs si vous nous rejoignez il est
21h30 heure française
outre manche londres envisage un
durcissement de sa politique migratoire
le ministre de l'intérieur a dévoilé
hier un arsenal de mesures qui seront
mises en place dès l'année prochaine
le nombre de migrants illégaux a
augmenté face à la crise sanitaire
mathilde euros maniant des migrants
escorté par les autorités britanniques
dans le port de douvres
comme beaucoup d'autres avant eux ils
ont tenté de traverser la manche à la
nage pour rejoindre le royaume uni
depuis les côtes françaises
les images datent du mois d'août mais ce
type d'opération se multiplient les
autorités françaises estiment à 6200 le
nombre de migrants ayant tenté de
traverser la manche depuis la france
cette année un record
londres veut donc affiché sa fermeté à
winchester je vais donc introduire un
nouveau système qui soit fermé juste
juste et compatissant envers ceux qui
ont besoin de notre aide
juste en accueillant les gens par des
voitures est légal mais ferme car nous
mettrons fin aux abus du système ferme
parce que nous arrêtons ceux qui
viennent ici illégalement et qui ne
cesse de mener des actions en justice
pour rester dans notre pays au détriment
du peuple britannique et ferme parce que
nous accélérons le renvoi de ceux qui
n'ont aucune demande légitime de
protection après des décennies
d'inaction des gouvernements successifs
nous aborderons les problèmes moraux
juridiques et pratiques du système
d'asile car ce qui existe actuellement
n'est ni fermi équitable d'enfer cet été
la hausse du nombre de migrants repêchés
par les forces frontalières britannique
a créé des tensions entre paris et
londres
fin août le gouvernement britannique a
demandé à la france des efforts
supplémentaires
mais avant de renforcer sa collaboration
avec les pays voisins le royaume uni
veut d'abord agir sur sa propre
législation priti patel accuse même
certains migrants de faire leur shopping
entre plusieurs pays pour demander
l'asile un système d'asile équitable
devrait offrir un refuge sûr à ceux qui
fuient la persécution l'oppression et la
tire
ni mais le nôtre ne le fait pas parce
que notre système d'asile est
fondamentalement brisé et nous avons la
responsabilité d'agir
à l'heure actuelle les plus vulnérables
sont coincés dans ce système défectueux
avec plus de 40 mille autres personnes
près de la moitié de ces demandes
prennent un an ou plus pour parvenir à
une décision ce qui coûte aux
contribuables britanniques plus d'un
milliard de livres par an le montant le
plus élevé depuis près de deux décennies
et à cause de notre système défectueux
arrivée dans notre pays ne change rien à
la manière dont leur demande et traitées
l'enjeu n'est pas que migratoires ou
humain il est aussi politique le
gouvernement britannique sous la
houlette du premier ministre boris
johnson a fait du contrôle de
l'immigration après le break site un
cheval de bataille
londres veut montrer qu'elle peut faire
mieux que l'union européenne en matière
de contrôle des migrants selon l'agencé
frontex
trente six mille quatre cents personnes
sont entrés illégalement sur le
territoire européen
au cours du premier semestre 2020 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
henry président de l'association france
fraternité pierre-henri merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
l'a entendu en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale le gouvernement
britannique se veut très ferme comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer c'est
l'effet breakes site
oui on sait l'effet breakes site et puis
c'est une tendance c'est naturel chez
nos amis britanniques de s'isoler et
puis c'était près de 20 ans que cette
question migratoire est à l'agenda
politique
la grande bretagne a fait pression sur
la france pour que cette dernière en
réalité face la police
noyer dans un certain nombre de subsides
jour apple qui lie à un traité entre la
grande bretagne et la france qui
s'appelle le traité du touquet qui a été
revisité en janvier 2018 et qui
transfère de fait à la france
la charge de contrôler les frontières
du côté de calais et d'empêcher un
certain nombre de passages donc vers la
grande-bretagne donc c'est une position
assez classique du gouvernement
conservateur qui avait promis d'ailleurs
pour ses lecteurs à l'opinion publique
en grande bretagne qu'avec le brix et il
n'y aurait plus d'immigration est
évidemment c'était un gros mensonge
il y a toujours de l'immigration en
grande-bretagne
aujourd'hui le discours oui oui la
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur on l'a
entendu elle souhaite organiser une
refonte complète du système de demande
d'asile elle le juge fondamentalement
défaillant est-ce que sur ce constat
vous la rejoignent et est ce que le
système est vraiment défaillants comme
le souligne prix pitt ribatel il ya de
gros problèmes en grande bretagne autour
de ce système
d'abord il y a une durée d'examen qui
est extrêmement longue
plus d'un an mais le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile en grande bretagne
n'a rien à voir avec le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile qui était cueilli par
les principaux pays sur le continent
le nombre de demandeurs d'asile c'est
environ 40000 en grande bretagne et
17000 accepté pour mémoire pour
l'allemagne où pour la france de sable
aux alentours de 140 mille annuellement
donc il ya eu manifestement un discours
à destination de l'opinion publique
en fait ce que deal secrétaire la
secrétaire d'état
c'est qu'elle veut remettre en cause la
capacité des demandeurs d'asile à faire
appel des décisions en première instance
qui sont prises et qui sut leur sont
défavorables dans le système c'est quand
même assez particulier de la part d'un
pays qui est le chantre de la démocratie
que de refuser
ou de préparer en tout cas un dispositif
qui empêche d'avoir recours devant la
justice quand une décision est négative
mais vous savez la grande bretagne est
une île ça n'aura pas changé de main et
donc la tentation de l'externalisation a
toujours existé depuis tony blair a
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien de
véritablement changé alors oui tiens il
selon la presse
il est de même plusieurs propositions
comme envoyer les demandeurs d'asile sur
un des territoires au milieu de
l'atlantique transformé de vieux ferry
en centre pour migrants ou encore
générer des vagues dans la manche est ce
que c'est de la provocation volontaire
selon vous pourquoi comment vous vous
comprenez ça oui mais c'est évidemment
de la provocation c'est mais voilà alors
de la provocation faut faire attention
parce que de cette provocation peut
surgir des monstres on a vu des systèmes
qui se sont mis en place par exemple en
australie ou littéralement les
demandeurs d'asile étaient placés sur
des îles lalizolle banc et c'est enfin
la grande bretagne n'est pas le str ali
elle a un rôle à jouer et à continuer à
jouer
d'ailleurs en europe et dans le monde
et je rappelle que les demandeurs
d'asile qui arrive en grande bretagne
sont pour la plupart des personnes qui
viennent des anciennes colonies de la
grande bretagne et qu'il me semble que
la grande bretagne doit prendre sa part
de l'accueil
elle doit le faire dans un système
équilibré et les propositions qui sont
celles
qui sont formulées aujourd'hui ne le
sont pas alors on verra ce qui va sortir
de ddd du secrétariat d'état mais je
voudrais quand même vous préciser
qu'aujourd'hui la grande bretagne des
systèmes de rétention les plus dures en
europe lorsque les demandeurs d'asile
sont mis parce qu'ils sont en situation
irrégulière en rétention
ça peut durer des années la rétention
est illimité et aujourd'hui le système
d'accueil est totalement sinistré
et comme les procédures durent très
longtemps
en réalité les demandeurs d et qui sont
dans cette procédure ont environ 5 euros
60 pour survivre autrement dit la
destination grande bretagne est une
destination qui et qui continue à être
sur banc du par les passeurs mais qui
n'a rien à voir avec la réalité de la
grande bretagne et je pense que il faut
absolument trouver les voies d'une
équipe d'un équilibre notamment entre
l'union européenne et la grande bretagne
ça fera forcément partie du deal qui
sera proposé et qui continuent dans les
quartiers dans le cadre du du break site
merci en tout cas ben c'est rory d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association
france fraternité amérique du sud
maintenant les chiliens se prononceront
le 25 octobre prochain sur le processus
de révision constitutionnelle un
référendum pour déterminer s'il faut
changer la constitution héritée de
l'année
de la dictature d'augusto pinochet la
consultation devait avoir lieu le 26
avril dernier mais elle a dû être
reportée en raison du comité 19 et
l'épidémie risque d'influencer le
scrutin alors que le pays est toujours
secoué par des manifestations violentes
contre les inégalités françois ti stevic
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nouveaux appontements c'est dimanche
dans les rues de santiago entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
plusieurs centaines de personnes
s'étaient réunies place d'italie contre
les violences policières après qu'un
jeune homme a été grièvement blessé lors
d'un rassemblement contre les inégalités
dans la capitale chilienne ce vendredi
pendant des affrontements entre une
partie des manifestants et la police
la victime est tombée dans le fleuve
mapocho dans des circonstances encore
floues
une enquête est en cours des violences
alors que le 25 octobre prochain les
près de 15 millions d'électeurs chilien
devront répondre à la question voulez
vous une nouvelle constitution
en optant pour l'option j'approuve où je
refuse mais également décider à quels
types d'organes citoyens ou
parlementaire il souhaite confier sa
rédaction
une constitution votée en 1980 en pleine
dictature d'augusto pinochet
nous pensons que ce moment historique
que nous vivons est très important c'est
l'occasion de jeter la constitution de
rémy guzmán et de pinochet qui ne nous
permet pas d'avancer défectueux de
grandes transformations les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés au
pouvoir depuis le retour de la
démocratie en 1990 n'ont pas su ou voulu
lancer une réforme d'envergure de la
constitution dans son programme
électoral de 2010 est sebastian pinera
l'actuel président du chili
n'envisageait d'ailleurs que de simples
en réformes progressives destinées à
améliorer le texte en vigueur
mais il écarté toute rupture mais depuis
le 18 octobre 2019
le chili est secoué par une crise
sociale marquée par un désir de
changement de constitution des
manifestants et le 15 novembre
la coalition gouvernementale et les
principaux partis d'opposition
parviennent à un accord historique sur
l'organisation d'un référendum
initialement prévue le 26 avril dernier
il a dû être reportée en raison de
l'épidémie de coronavirus selon les
derniers sondages trois chiliens sur
quatre serait d'accord pour adopter une
nouvelle constitution et pour en parler
nous sommes avec pierre le bret
politologue spécialiste de l'amérique
latine bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors depuis
maintenant presque un an des
manifestations secouent le pays pour
dénoncer la faiblesse du système chilien
la mort d'un manifestant le 2 octobre a
ravivé les tensions
point de situation est-ce que c'est à
nouveau très tendue dans les rues de
santiago ces derniers jours il ya une
polarisation politique très extrême
sociales et politiques
mais finalement ce référendum du 25
octobre prochain
c'est la prise de responsabilité du
peuple chilien
face à un gouvernement qui a abandonné
les siennes en étant les auteurs
politique de la répression contre le
contre le peuple chilien qui dure depuis
le 18 octobre dernier
c'est à dire que depuis le début des
manifestations dont il ya bientôt un an
le gouvernement de sebastian pinera n'a
pas montré une réelle volonté de
réformer le pays c'est plutôt le peuple
chilien qui pousse à réformer le pays
qui poussent à ajustement à la avoir un
référendum le 25 octobre prochain
mais il ya eu une violation systématique
des droits de l'homme depuis le 18
octobre dernier il faut se rappeler
quand même des décharges dans la rue au
mois de novembre dernier en 2019
il y a eu selon le procureur général de
la république plus de 1000 de plus de
8500 violations présumées des droits de
l'homme et la police vient et bien
évidemment mise et devant les fêtes
finalement on a bien vu de manifestants
qui a été poussé par deux sur un pont
sur la rivière à santiago
c'est inacceptable et je me demande
vraiment si la france ou des pays comme
la france sont capables de condamner le
venezuela il faudra en faire de même
avec le gouvernement chilien
alors concernant ce référendum
aujourd'hui 75% des chiliens un bulletin
un changement de constitution
pour autant est-ce qu'un retournement de
situation est possible ou alors je vous
dirais les dés sont jetés
non moi je pense que je pense que
l'enjeu il sera après de vote
c'est à dire sur l'option que les chiens
vont choisir soit une constituante qui
sera justement avec qui sera composé
avec des personnalités issues de la
société civile soit une convention mixte
avec des parlementaires des
personnalités des partis politiques
apparemment l'option de la constituante
l'emporterait le 25 octobre
mais comme vous dites les dés sont jetés
je ne sais pas en tout cas je pense que
selon les sondages on est entre 75 et 85
% des chiliens et chiliennes qui serait
pour un changement de constitution parce
qu'il ya une grande fatigue face aux
inégalités d'une constitution issue de
la dictature vous l'avez très bien dit
dans votre note avant avant cette
intervention
donc je pense que voilà la fatique des
chiliens et chiliennes vont finalement
se transparente et dans les urnes dans
les semaines à venir quand comment se
déroule la campagne justement en ce
moment à ce qu'elle est elle est très
suivi par les chiliens dans ce contexte
un vous le disiez de violences
policières de manifestations en période
d'épidémie également est ce qu'elle est
très suivi par les chiliens cette
campagne je pense qu'elle est suivie et
pas seulement maintenant on a vu quand
même depuis pendant de confinement les
chiliens étaient tous à leur balcon avec
des cas tapé sur des casseroles
justement s'opposer à la politique
gouvernementale pour s'opposer à toute
la répression qui avait eu auparavant et
après mon droite qui fait campagne
voilà une droite extrême qui fait
campagne pour le refus de changement de
constitution qui est une droite plutôt
pinochetiste
et une gauche qui est quand même assez
divisés mais qui fait campagne également
dans les rues j'ai vu des images il n'y
a pas très longtemps dans les rues de
santiago dans les rues du pays pour la
l'option j'approuve et est-ce qu'il ya
eu des figures qui se sont qui sont
sortis un peu du lot ces derniers mois
pendant les manifestations
figure qui pourrait être portée par le
peuple chilien
oh oui il ya des figures le problème de
la gauche aujourd'hui c'est la division
comme dans beaucoup de pays
mais il ya des figures comme le maire de
recoleta la municipalité pas très loin
de la commune de santiago daniel razoux
et il ya aussi mal qu'au sein des
caisses ominami qui a fait pas mal de
l'intervention justement pour condamner
la politique gouvernementale pour qu'on
donnait toutes ces répressions
mais voilà vous avez une gauche
multipartisme il ya beaucoup de partis à
gauche et à droite ils sont plutôt ils
sont plutôt là il ya il ya moins de
division - de fragmentation alors il ya
aussi un set cette pandémie covit 19 qui
touche le monde entier est ce que le
scrutin est ce que cette épidémie pour
influencer le scrutin
mais il ya vraiment des préoccupations
vis-à-vis de ça à bon moi je pense que
c'est ce qui est très important c'est
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités pour le voilà pour la
tenir des gestes barrières pour préparer
la population à ce type à ce type de
vote dans un contexte très particulier
mais je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
envie de changement
actuellement je donc voilà je pense pas
que ça ait un effet démobilisateur de la
société chilienne pour le référendum de
la fin du mois alors pour conclure quel
impact ce scrutin pourrait avoir sur la
classe politique on en parlait un peu
tout à l'heure dans le cas où il y
aurait un changement de constitution est
ce que cela pourrait réellement apaiser
des tensions en cours dans le pays
à partir du moment où il y aura un
vraiment
un réel débat sur qu'est ce que nous
voulons dans la constitution
dans ce nouveau texte constitutionnel
voilà c'est une chance et une
opportunité même des artistes disait
l'autre jour que c'était quelque chose
de magique parce qu'il n'y avait pas eu
cette opportunité là lors de la
transition à la démocratie inachevée
finalement en 1990 donc voilà c'est une
opportunité je pense que les chiliens et
chiliennes on en a envie
pour sortir de cette injustice sociale
et pour briser aussi un système
néolibéral qui n'a fait que reproduire
des inégalités l'éducation privée le
système de retraite par capitalisation
donc voilà il ya vraiment des enjeux
mais voilà c'est un premier pas le
processus assez long parce que c'est un
référendum donc fin octobre ensuite pour
mois d'avril prochain seront choisis les
membres de la constituante
et voilà donc ces voix là il y aura de
nombreux débats mais la question c'est
est-ce que le gouvernement chilien va
arrêter la répression
merci beaucoup pierre le bret pour votre
éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
c'est la fin de cette émission et on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes à 22
heures précises heure de paris pour un
point complet sur l'actualité a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible partir du moment où le brizault
rico nos métiers revient à la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peu près
allons parler de climat insurrectionnel
en côte d'ivoire si on permettait aux
ivoiriens de manifester est libre
d'exprimer leurs opinions en toute
liberté
il n'y aurait pas de cantine et nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signé à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président entre hommes va décider de
rompre l'accord et d'imposer son régime
de sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avait t'il un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de bon au moyen-orient
[Musique]
couleur dans les banques où la diversité
c'est un autre point fort pas notre
point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
cercle ohada et tout le monde discute et
finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois vous voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus c'est pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
ne va pas être violent et on va rester
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même le
corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi le taux de fiabilité du
projet ne serait ce qu'au business et on
oscille entre 92 et 98 5%
elle fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
d'épaisseur on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait aux peut-être
faire en sorte qu on fasse appel à
savoir faire qui est un savoir-faire
médical aussi dans un domaine un peu
différente et celui de l'animal mais
après tout l'homme c'est un animal peu
plus
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien j'ai un bac sonar
haut ni la gravité la date en 2000 il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là ou si je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
de la daube ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité une
troupe est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rodolphe gombergh vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait
avancer là l'image est belle mais mais
en général le mal qu'elle révèle
il est terrifiant au moment du coup vite
quand j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
3d de virton life a pour mon thorax
propres et pour le virus j'ai pu suivre
son évolution comme henry ça s'aggravait
ou au contraire comment ça c'est mc
veigh quand on a découvert le colis dont
on sait qu on sait comment ils et
comment voir quelle couleur il est qu'on
a découvert le mal les belges du mal
[Musique]
de nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
deux semaines avec la fermeture des bars
clubs de sport piscine ou bien encore
les universités contraintes de l'umih de
limiter leur capacité d'accueil paris et
la proche banlieue sont passés en état
d' alerte maximale depuis hier soir elle
les restaurants revanche peuvent rester
ouverts dans la capitale avec un
protocole sanitaire renforcée ceux de la
région de marseille sont rouverts la
cité phocéenne va d'ailleurs se doter de
son propre conseil scientifique pour
évaluer la situation sanitaire
[Musique]
outre atlantique donald trump sortira de
l'hôpital cette nuit à 00h30 heure
française dans un tweet il annonce se
sentir très bien le médecin de la maison
blanche lui est moins optimiste le
président n'est peut-être pas encore
complètement tiré d'affaires deux sons
de cloche qui sème à nouveau la
confusion
tout au long de sa contamination les
annonces contradictoires pour semer le
trouble sur son état de santé dans son
entourage sa porte parole est également
testé positif
[Musique]
dans le territoire disputé du haut
karabagh les troubles séparatistes se
retire je cite de certains secteurs du
front à des fins tactiques indique la
présidence de cette république
autoproclamée engagé dans un conflit
armé avec l'azerbaïdjan voilà neuf jours
maintenant que s'affrontent les forces
séparatistes arménienne et l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise
vladimir poutine a appelé à l'arrêt
immédiat des combats
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt français on débute avec
l'actualité du jour en france dominée
par les nouvelles mesures de restriction
pour paris et sa petite couronne on le
rappelle placées en zones d'alerté
maximale le préfet de police de paris
didier lallement et la mère anne hidalgo
ont tenu à midi une conférence de presse
est les bars seront fermés les
restaurants dont l'activité principale
est la vente d'alimentation pourront eux
restés ouverts à les piscines également
fermé mais accessible aux mineurs tous
les équipements de plein air pourront
rester ouverts à condition de rassembler
moins de 1000 personnes ou 50% de leur
capacité maximale
il ya les centres commerciaux pourront
accueillir au maximum un client pour
quatre mètres carrés à des visites
peuvent se faire sur rendez-vous dans
les ehpad dans les universités la
capacité d'accueil est réduite à 50% à
marseille la lutte contre le coc vite 19
prend une nouvelle tournure la deuxième
adjointe de la ville samia ghali a
rappelé aujourd'hui sa volonté de créer
un conseil scientifique et l'idée a été
adopté lors du conseil municipal ce
lundi à plus d'explications avec
cyrielle benavides bulbul lire la cité
phocéenne en quête d'indépendance du
moins d'indépendance sanitaires pour
cela la deuxième adjointe à la mairie
samia ghali après initiative inédite
je pense qu'il est important de créer un
conseil scientifique de la ville de
marseille avec les collectivités la
préfecture
li a chu l'ap-hm l'hôpital privé
les marins-pompiers voir la cci
l'éducation nationale tous ces
organismes qui sont au contact de la
situation sanitaire au quotidien il faut
permettre à la mère de marseille d'avoir
des discussions sur le co vide et
d'autres questions et faire en sorte que
des personnalités marseillaise puisse
discuter et faire des propositions
plutôt que de laisser faire l'état la
proposition de l'ancienne sénatrice qui
avaient émergé à la fin du mois d'avril
a été validé par le conseil municipal ce
lundi marseille va se doter de son